Michael in your pitch video for love
touch hate to say it's the story of a
man Bradley who transfers love with his
touch and every time he touches someone
they instantly fall in love with him and
that says you said that it brings love
into his life but it's sort of painful
and also beautiful at the same time you
said it was a very sort of painful
process writing about this character or
thinking about it why but for me as a
writer it's about you know as a writer
you have to kind of dive into your your
heroes world per se and in the case of
the hit of the hero and the movie love
touch hate he's completely isolated from
everybody and he's not the sense that
it's like he's isolated like he lives in
a cave somewhere he literally he has
people all around him and they love him
but none of them know him and she like
go into the world of having that of
having every single person you know uh
kind of not respect you and not connect
with you uh is very very dark and very
extremely lonely it to me it's like more
lonely than like i said be on an
isolated deserted island somewhere you
are just completely alone even though
you communicate with people that make
sense
you